шановні українці от просто вам для
інформації під стенограмою де призначені
одного з ключових віце-прем'єрів Як ви
думаєте кандидат слухає зараз виступи із
залу ні Як ви думаєте прем'єр-міністр
зараз слухається виступи із залу також
ні просто Зверніть увагу на це ви не
бачите цього по телевізору але я вам
просто підсонограму це фіксую
тепер що стосується
цього призначення Давайте так
міністерство інфраструктури Чи все там
було добре Ну звичайно ні я почув як
пане Олександр сказав що зараз мірило
таке Наскільки ти допомагаєш армії де ми
всі в цій залі пам'ятаємо як гроші з
армії забиралися на дороги і саме цих
грошей можливо не вистачило десь на
початках війни що стосується
Міністерства регіонального розвитку ну
слухайте майже вбили місцеве
самоврядування поговоріть з мерами
поговоріть з главами отг вони вам все
розкажуть про це
що стосується зараз то перед
віце-прем'єром міністром які виклики
стануть можливо послухайте стенограму
після того знаєте отримає
перше Головне щоб це відновлення не
стало черговим великим крадівництвом бо
ви знаєте ви Підійдіть в Бучу і Спитаєте
думку людей в яких не було вікон дахів
від дверей а не їх очах їм казали що
нема грошей а не їх очах робили дороги
прям зараз оце після звільнення друге ви
подивіться другий виклик це буде хаос у
владі бо сьогодні ми чуємо від п
Олександра що він тут нахвалює діам в
сфері архітектури і будівництва а тут
залі Зараз знесений закон Я фактично
який вбиває цей діам Слухайте ну вашого
права рука не знає що робить ліва і
третій виклик цей міжнародна допомога бо
у всіх перед очами досі приклад лугану
яке було майже завалене ну майже Це я
так м'яко сказав воно було реально
завалене і жодного
жодної допомоги звідти Ми не отримали
тому виклики серйозні будемо сподіватися
що ситуація не стане гірше дякую